I think I just want to say you just came
out here right now dancing like a
leprechaun and then I want to say I've
known you for a long time you look
incredibly fit you look Thank You slim
and fit and I bring us up for a reason
for years you had a job on Parks and Rec
where it was your job to stay a little
chunky is that not the case it's true
yeah when the show got picked up our
bosses said you know sometimes when
shows get picked up people go to the gym
and get trimmed down and get hair plugs
and we would appreciate it this is set
in Indiana so don't get any more
gorgeous then you already are you are
Indiana gorgeous yeah so they wanted you
to keep that sort of that Midwest
regular guy appeal
yeah make sure our creator said I like
you beefy and I'd like you to stay beefy
and you could even take it to husky if
you feel like take it up to husky now
because Huskies right one notch above
the beefy and what about well Chris
Pratt was on that show did he I mean did
he have to work out and things like that
or was he allowed to know yeah this is
pre superhero Chris Pratt also a denizen
of Indiana
yeah so we enjoyed eating a great deal
of fatty meats together but he's a big
guy I mean he's a big it really play pro
football he's that big and so he could I
mean you know my trick was I would eat
just a second cheeseburger that was my
technique he would just regale himself
with literally a dozen racks of ribs
right just giggling the whole time
giggling and licking his fingers yeah
well we all slowly wept with jealousy
yeah because you only got to have two
cheeseburgers you know it's funny Ron
Swanson the character famously part of
his character was used to meet lover and
believed in meat and the and the power
of just meat eating when that did that
ever get you special treatment in a
restaurant say oh sure ya know for years
even to this day when I'm in a
restaurant I will often you know
the way people will send you over a
drink in a bar
yeah people send me over a porterhouse
[Laughter]
[Music]
from the gentleman with did this how was
this for your health was your doctor
okay with all this it was great for my
mood and my pelt yeah hmm was shiny but
eventually eventually my doctor said
your your artery walls are very thick
and that's not great that's not supposed
to be great now we want to thin them so
so I cut it you know I cut down to like
87% red meat diet that's an inspiration
to a lot of people watching right now
you can do it if you can get down to 87%
red meat you are a proud proud American
you